[Music]
imagine you had to experience an
apocalypse
every day
volcanic eruptions
tsunamis
asteroid showers
every day would be a struggle for
survival
that's because Earth is now a moon of
Jupiter
why are we being hit by so many
asteroids
could we survive in underground bunkers
and how much damage would Jupiter's
gravity cause
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Earth orbited Jupiter
now that we've joined Jupiter's 79 other
moons let's scope out our new
neighborhood
Jupiter is the largest planet in our
solar system it's so big that it could
hold over 1300 Earths inside it yeah for
perspective think of the Earth as a
grape compared to us Jupiter would be
the size of a basketball
it would be a heck of a view though
Jupiter would take up an enormous chunk
of the sky
but once you're done stargazing you'd
notice how cold it's gotten
that's because Jupiter is
778 million kilometers away from the Sun
the nice warm sun
that means 25 times less luminosity and
25 times less heat than we have right
now
and that's only a small taste of what's
changed
one year on Earth is the length of one
month on Jupiter since it takes Jupiter
12 years to go around the Sun
if we were to compare Earth to Jupiter's
closest Moon I'll your days would be
about 40 hours long
but the good news is it'll give you lots
of time to prepare
look alive you've got some work to do
if you want to survive out here you'd
need to go underground
you and all of humanity would set up
shop in Subterranean bunkers
now don't be expecting a five-star bed
and breakfast all right you'll be
surrounded by thick tightly sealed
concrete walls so no gas water or
radiation can get through and before you
get nice and settled you'll need to
ensure your bunker has a reliable power
source a sound air filtration system and
apple food and water supply
if you really feel like a Hermit you
could convince your Vault survival crew
to build hydroponic Farms these Farms
use nutrient-rich water and artificial
light to grow plants instead of the
usual soil and sunlight combo
and speaking of sunlight you're gonna
miss it a lot because you're now living
underground you'll be lacking in the
vitamin D Department
a workaround might be introducing some
fish into your survival diet
using aquaponics fish and plants can be
farmed together even indoors
and eating fish will provide you with
that sweet essential vitamin D your body
is craving
I know it sounds like a lot of work but
trust me it's worth it you wouldn't want
to live on the surface
that's because topside there's a daily
apocalypse
the gravitational pull from Jupiter's
other nearby moons not to mention the
planet itself would generate extreme
tidal forces
the whole world would be falling apart
literally
Monday you'd have to deal with an
earthquake
Tuesday it's volcanic eruptions
Wednesdays you've got tsunamis
by the weekend you've got the worst of
all
steroid impacts
every month June
by anywhere from 12 to 60 comets or
asteroids
now the good news is Jupiter will take
the Lion's Share of the bombardment but
the bad news is the ones that hit us
could still do some serious damage
Jupiter's gravitational pull makes
asteroids move faster it's basically an
asteroid with a nitrous speed boost
reaching a collision speed of about 216
000 kilometers per hour and that's just
the minimum if Earth became one of
Jupiter's moons we'd be directly in the
line of fire
one event like this occurred in 1994
when the Shoemaker Levy 9 Comet collided
with Jupiter
if we took the hit instead of Jupiter
the two kilometer long comet would
strike us like a shotgun blast
seriously because of Jupiter's Gravity
the comet would break up into 20 pieces
and the collisions from these fragments
would be like getting hit by 300 million
atomic bombs
flumes of debris would shoot as high as
3 000 kilometers and that's not all
these hits would cause our atmosphere to
reach scorching temperatures of around
40
000 degrees Celsius
you know why they called it the
Shoemaker because it just kicked our
planet's ass
but let's say Jupiter took one for the
team and the asteroids missed us well
you're not out of the woods yet
as you peeked your head out of the
bunker to look at the surface you'd
realize your geiger counter is going
crazy
the weather today highly irradiated
if you lingered too long and got hit
with 200 RADS you'd experience radiation
sickness
you could look forward to vomiting
fatigue and diarrhea but still You'd
Survive
once you go past 200 RADS however things
would go from bad to worse
and for the record rad is radiation
absorbed dose it puts a number on how
much energy your body absorbed from
radiation
and even as little as two RADS can cause
chromosomal damage
except Jupiter's magnetic field is 10
times stronger than Earth's meaning that
it emits a million times more radiation
at 400 RADS you'd really start to hurt
your chances of dying would reach 50
percent and you could feel your
intestines and Marrow falling apart at
600 RADS you'd be dead
so you might want to go back inside the
bunker but before you do take in that
view one last time you'd be able to see
some of Jupiter's other moons like
Callisto Ganymede and IO if you looked
closely enough you could even witness
io's volcanoes erupting even cooler the
Aurora would be a full-time light show
thanks to Jupiter's radiation
beautiful isn't it
oh okay back in the bunker back in the
bunker pack it up
feels so good
if Earth orbited Jupiter it's safe to
say things would be less than ideal but
what if we turned the tables and
Jupiter's 80 moons came to us
would it be a paradise or a cosmic
disaster
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]